[Music]
this week on the dish we take you to
philadelphia to meet brothers benjamin
and robert bynum they do have been on
philadelphia's food and music scene for
decades offering up southern inspired
food and preserving the city's rich jazz
tradition a history intertwined with
their own family
[Music]
[Applause]
it's south jazz club it's about harmony
and improvisation
on stage
and in the kitchen an experience
carefully crafted by brothers benjamin
and robert bynum complete with a modern
take on classic southern dishes what is
soul food to you i think every culture
has soul food and i think it's something
that
evokes warm feelings childhood memories
time spent with family i was treated to
a feast reminiscent of my grandmother's
table with dishes like seafood stew
deviled eggs red rice and brown sugar
pineapple bread pudding in all the years
i've done dishes i don't think i've ever
had this much food plated for me i gotta
dig in
[Music]
this red rice is so delicious thank you
so much i appreciate it
oh my gosh benjamin who has formal
culinary training tries to make these
dishes as healthy as possible ben used
to be a smoker
how did you know that
i quit because i
began to feel the effects of smoking and
the effects of unhealthy eating so he
decided his soul food menu needed a diet
too
this food is traditional soul food but
it's rather light the stereotype of
southern food is
it's fried chicken and catfish i
wouldn't have felt right not to do one
of those dishes since it is something
that is part of what we do and it's
something that is part of our history
and our culture but there are certainly
methods and ways to cook food that's
full of flavor that
you know you're not pushing the envelope
with your cholesterol and everything but
i'm not going to lie to you it's a lot
of cheese and butter yeah there it is
there is no getting around the mac and
cheese
benjamin invited me into the kitchen to
make one of south's popular dishes the
blue crab toast we're going to make the
lemon caper ravigote it's a fancy way
for sand lemon horseradish mayonnaise
horseradish scallions mustard lemon
juice mayo and lump crab meat on toasted
brioche and then we have our avocado and
lemon
juice salt and pepper and we take that
and we just do a nice little
[Applause]
[Music]
that's our blue crabs there it is check
that out look at this
i did it all by myself
you enjoy a nice a nice evening of
dinner and then come next door into the
jazz club to listen to a set of music
the front of the house is robert's
domain the wharton grad mimics the
60-year career of his late father
benjamin bynum senior he owned the
cadillac club which later became impulse
posting the likes of aretha franklin
nina simone and fats domino when you
think about your dad's club and what it
meant
to the folks who were employed there to
the community that it served
what was it that it provided that
no place else could
the impulse was at broad germantown
which might be considered to be a
low-income area and he made a commitment
to the community to have a place that
was upscale elegant and treated people
in a manner that they
might not be treated every place so they
really felt like it was a refuge within
the community so service was
really important to your family very
much so i mean it was a safe haven kind
of for us um you know we grew up at that
time uh it's in the heart of north
philadelphia it used to be called
yorktown
it was
a challenging area but i think that
it was a place where people enjoyed
getting dressed up and going which was a
little bit unusual for those times since
1990 the brothers picked up the reigns
with six restaurants in philadelphia
including zanzibar blue open from 1990
to 2007. you opened the club when jazz
was on the decline
how much part of keeping that tradition
alive was zanzibar blue
philadelphia has a rich jazz tradition
and we felt like things have begun to
slide a little bit so we were very
committed to presenting
upscale
environment with really big names we did
blue raws we did chichoria we've done
jimmy scott we've done nancy wilson so
we were really committed to bringing
back jazz to the city of philadelphia
benjamin bynum senior also worked with
his sons at their longest running eatery
warm daddies he died at the age of 98
just last year he uh handled our door at
warren daddy's for for many many years
he only stopped
probably a year or so before he passed
away and he was very much our rock he
was very much who we relied on to bounce
ideas off and to be supportive of what
we were doing
so it was a loss but we still have his
legacy to hold on to the brothers
decided to close warm daddies during the
pandemic but continue to serve up food
and music at relish and here at south
the ultimate celebration of their
father's legacy business is good
people are coming back people are coming
back the vaccine mandate has been lifted
the mass mandate has just been lifted in
philadelphia so that's really made a big
difference to folks and people are
coming out and i think the feeling
beginning to feel a lot more comfortable
really we've been fortunate to have a
very loyal clientele that supports us at
all of our venues so
that's something that is uh
been reassuring to us
[Music]
and nothing gets those guys too excited
i mean they're very even keel it's how
they run the business and how they've
been able to run it for so long of
course i brought you some goodies here
we have everything from mac and cheese
to their cornbread the blue crab toast
that i
made myself
deviled eggs there's catfish and and uh
shrimp and seafood bouillabaisse but the
one thing they did not bring was my
absolute or sin was my absolute favorite
why what was the pineapple bread pudding
oh the best bread pudding i have ever
had i love bread pudding folks in new
orleans uh i got something to tell you
what i hate to break that news to you
was better than new orleans own what
whoa i'm not kidding you michelle
talking smack about your life i'm
talking smack about my what do we got
here is this a side car oh this yeah
styling cheers cheers folks cheers nice
to have you here jamie nice piece
michelle thank you